well thank you Tom for that introduction
I think it's the most fun bio I've ever
heard it's really I've been a listener
of a TTL for many years so it's actually
great to be here today the last time I
was here was actually five years ago I
came to listen to my longtime mentor
Katherine Cole she actually helped us
bring pair up and she was one of the
first female venture capitalists in the
valley but not only that she was
actually one of the best venture
capitalists in the valley and sadly she
passed away nine months after her ETL
seminar so today I thought I would take
just a couple seconds to remember her
and actually encourage all of you to
listen to her presentation I think it's
all worth it I am going to start the
talk by giving a little Twitter style
bio and then I will get to DoubleTap on
what I do today and finally I'll get to
the meat of the talk so this is my bio
Twitter style I was born in Barcelona
Spain and I spent my childhood on my
teenage years there I actually spent one
my sophomore year in high school in
Kansas City Missouri I I was always a
very messy kid I liked to do math and
even when I would go outside in the
playground I was looking for patterns
and doing math in my head which drove my
parents nuts
I liked soccer and I loved FC Barcelona
I still do that today in 95 I came to
Stanford I did a lot of piaying
and I ended up leaving with a PhD in
electrical engineering as Tom said in 99
I started a company called Barcelona
design this company went all the way up
and then all the way down and I'll talk
about it
but I had my first baby Isaac so that
was a good time I started my second
company in 2004 it was called Savio I
sold it to a public company
I spent some years they're running
engineering and product and I had two
more babies on the way and finally I
decided I was I had to get out of
semiconductors try something new so I
went
to investing I did mobile e-commerce and
finally I started pair with my team and
went back into teaching so I'll double
tap on the last bullet
first of all pair I have a three slides
we are a seed stage fund and we partner
with founders really early on what we
call at zero and we try to do whatever
we can to help them build successful
companies I founded it with my business
partner - Mendoza in 2013 we are
investing out of a fund that is a
hundred and sixty million dollars and
we're a team of twelve people and this
is actually a picture of our team that
we took nine months ago it's not our
official picture if you actually go to
our web page we have really fancy
pictures take it in a studio but I love
this pictures like the robes picture
because we're all dressed in our
uniforms and we post like a soccer team
and that's really our culture I pair I
think when we have a success it's
because of all of us and when something
doesn't go right it's all of our fault
is nobody's fault right and I can trust
that everybody in our team has my back
so we do this a picture every year and I
really really like it I only have one
slide on real graphs but it's I think
it's important I've been working really
hard for the last six years to figure
out what how to get companies from zero
to one and zero every company has a day
zero right we call zero point five when
companies build a product that somebody
likes and we call one when that when you
figure out how to sell that product and
make money and that's zero to one
sometimes people call it product market
fit and it looks like this it's very
bumpy and feels like a roller coaster
but it's also fun and challenging and
that's what I like about it so that's
what we do and just the last light on us
like Tom mentioned we've had one IPO in
the last six years our companies have
raised oh five billion dollars and
they're worth almost thirty billion
dollars which is incredible these are
some of the companies that we backdoor -
branch garden Nova affinity Gus - many
more we are so fortunate to
work with the founders of this companies
who do obviously most of the work and
one interesting fact for everybody in
the audience is that all of these
companies were actually started by
Stanford alumni and many of them while
they were students here so that's really
exciting okay this is the other thing I
do in my free time I am part of the
teaching staff for lean launchpad which
is a class that is in engineering school
engineering 245 it's you know I was
actually the the reason I became a
teacher here was also because of
Katherine she introduced me to Steve
Blank who is the guy who's behind this
class
it's literally like an experiment for
ten weeks we take students and we try to
simulate what a startup feels like just
that zero to one stage the way to define
that classes were exercising that muscle
so when you are faced with that
situation in real life you know you have
some tools to figure it out
one of the nice things of this class and
I see many of the students here is that
I get to interact with great students
and its new people every year and so
full of energy is great it's not the
only time I get to interact with
students my daughter says I spent a lot
of time with students this is pictures
of what I've done over the last six
years but I do spend a lot of time with
students sometimes it's one-on-one
sometimes they're part of our investment
sometimes part of a pair program and
sometimes you know it's part of our my
outreach I do a lot of outreach for
female founders sometimes we all have
ice cream and get on both so it's all
sorts of activities but the great thing
is for with a few of them I have a deep
relationship and they feel comfortable
enough to come to me with their problems
so I have a little window onto what it
is to be a student at this institution
actually I know some of them so well
that one family weekend comes a
graduation I go out with their parents
out to dinner so that's actually really
fun so when I was preparing for the talk
today I thought what am I gonna talk
about this
I watched a lot of ETL videos and I'm
like everything has been
so I decided that I would answer some of
the questions and concerns and worries
that I get from the students that come
and talk to me so I hope some of them
will be useful to you let's start with
the first one and the first one is yes
it's really ok if your freshman
internship is not at Google right
and I know you laugh but it's true some
people are really scared if it's the end
of Fall Quarter and they don't have that
internship lined up and they're even
more worried if it's not at a fancy
place but the truth is it really doesn't
matter I think what really matters is
when you go to that first internship you
have to really give it your best no
matter what you do you have to give it
your best it's all attitude I think you
know one of the things I did this
weekend is actually figure out what the
CEOs of companies that went public in
2019 what were their first jobs that was
actually really interesting because they
were something like production shift
manager at Mars and advocate at some law
firm actually didn't know what an
advocate was whether it was above or
below a paralegal I didn't know and
brand assistant at Clorox so at least
this is proof that you don't need to
have a fancy internship to take a
company public and these are I'll tell
you now about my internships before grad
school I had two internships one was a
Apple and the other one was at a little
company called linear tech now of course
you can see from the buildings that
Apple just looks fancier and my parents
knew what Apple was they had no idea
what linear tech was but linear was
actually really important to me
linear was started in 1981 and it went
public in 1986 so five years which is
super record time these days and it got
bought by analog devices two years ago
for 15 billion dollars so it was
actually a good company it was known for
producing some of the highest quality
analog circuits in the world it also had
very very high operating margins as
close close to a software company which
was hard and perhaps the most
interesting is
employed all these people that were
super super smart the circuit analog
circuit designers and they had a special
name they weren't called engineers they
were called gurus and the place was
called the home of the gurus I'm sorry I
couldn't find a better picture but
that's that's where I went to work I got
the job by accident this is Bob defconn
he's the founder and CTO of the company
he happened to be a friend of my den
boyfriend and now husband so I met him
at a party and he was complaining that
he couldn't hire analog designers he had
John just gone to Berkeley which maybe
he should have gone somewhere else and
he didn't find anybody that would answer
his questions on RC oscillators I'm
sitting next to him and I just had
studied RC oscillators so I blurted out
the answer and he was so shocked that
this girl from Spain answered his
question that he gave me an internship
on the spot so that's how I got the job
I wasn't even looking for it and I was
excited because I was gonna be able to
spend the summer with my dad boyfriend
in mellow Park
so this come the surprises of this
internship first this internship was in
Milpitas and I don't know how many
people know where Milpitas is I was
surprised to find out some people don't
know where that is but it's 60 miles
south east of here and in 94 there was
no highway that would take you there so
and I didn't drive and there was no uber
so my only way to get to work was to
take a bus right actually had to take
two buses and walk so I looked it up on
Google and it still takes two hours to
get to Milpitas if you don't have a car
so if you do the math I was gonna spend
four hours you know public
transportation getting to me Oh Peters
that was my first surprise my second
surprise when I walked in I thought I
know the answer of this question I'm
gonna be a fancy circuit designer they
said oh no there's no desk for you and
we're now giving you a computer you can
have a lot bench if there's one free but
you're going to be working for the other
people and taking measurements so this
was a translation for like I have the
lowest job possible at this place
my third surprise was that I was going
to be the
first female that actually worked on the
in that lab and people didn't know how
to act in front of me I was like a
strange object so you know they they had
a they were really fun people very smart
and they had a culture of pranking each
other they were all these pranksters so
the first thing they did to me is they
put a very heavy inductor in my backpack
tiny but heavy so when I would walk for
this you know many hours back and forth
my back started hurting
so anyways it was pretty bad but uh
you know I was very lucky that guy in
the picture his name is Jim Williams
here he is Jim Williams somehow to pity
on me he was like his bench was in front
of mine and he decided he was going to
help me out and the first thing he did
was he gave me a writing so I would
drive from elloe Park to Milpitas in his
car that had the license plate analog I
don't think you could be much more of an
analogue designer the second thing is
that he gave me an education I think he
really cared for me and I didn't know at
the time but he was one of the people
that was best known for you know circuit
design he actually had pulled Lanier
Tech with him this is the way he thought
his brain was just uh you know mess
inside but then he had this magic power
of translating knowledge into foreign
dollars consumable by humans so he would
literally blurt out this application
notes he would even write books and he
had this art he had this kind of Miro
like art in his house that were all
circuits so I was so impressed with him
that I worked so hard to keep up with
him right so I learned a lot and
actually the the best thing about Jim is
who is the chief prankster in that lab
so the last week I was at linear he
decided that we were gonna get back at
the boys and we came in early and for
those ye in the audience they don't
understand the joke
we had a test board for testing voltage
regulators we went in and we flip the
polarity of all the electrolytic
capacitors and when you do
to a capacitor and you power it up it
literally blows up so you know when we
that day when they turn on the test
board it literally there was this
explosion in the lab I don't know if you
could do this today but you could 25
years ago so anyways that's my first
internship I didn't know and this is you
know what I got I was so happy that I
said and definitely found Jim Williams
and that he taught me a lot about
circuit design okay so that's concern
one anybody concern about that
internship you shouldn't be concerned
the second point that I get a lot is no
not everyone here is way smarter than
you are right and I know that you may
not believe it because everybody around
you is really really smart right but
everybody here is smart in different
ways and I think part of it is believing
in yourself everybody that I interact
with during class I know it's capable of
great stuff so I didn't always feel this
way in fact when I first came here to
Stanford I thought I had gotten in
because Bob wrote a recommendation
letter and I thought that Bob wrote the
recommendation letter cuz he just felt
so bad for me that I had worked so hard
linear but anyways I got in and Bob said
go see Greg Kovacs professor Greg Kovacs
is my friend and see what you can do so
I went there and Greg said oh why don't
you come to my research group we'll just
kind of like figure out if there is
something here for you so I showed up to
the research group meeting and their
tiny rooms and everybody first look
really tall but second they were
speaking a language that I could barely
understand and it got worse at some
point this guy she's my friend now John
Stehr he stood up and said oh I'm gonna
demo what I've done and he had this
little chip that it was kind of the
first autonomous micro robot it would
like move on the table and carry these
paper clips I'm like oh my gosh where am
I this place is crazy that people have
moving chips what am i doing so I
literally went home and Matt was still
my boyfriend at that point
he was a really smart person and I said
okay I quit I'm gonna go in tomorrow
maybe they'll give me my tuition back if
I'm lucky we have to figure out the visa
situation because I can't stay here
unless I have a visa and my husband Matt
said I remember he said listen do you
want to be the smartest person on that
research group or you want to be the
dumbest person because if you are the
dumbest person you're gonna learn
something it's like playing tennis you
always want to play up you don't want to
have your tennis class with somebody
that is worse than you and at least that
was enough to get me through the next
few days
so I eventually did graduate there's a
picture of my graduation but the time
that I was here I want to tell for
anybody in the audience was actually
really really hard I was always feeling
like I didn't belong I would go through
this cycle I actually for those E's in
the audience they know that if you want
to get a PhD you have to take this exam
called the Qualls and it's very
mystified cuz you know it's part of the
story but I was completely convinced I
would never pass the Qualls right I was
just convinced I was so scared that I
wouldn't even look at the results so I
had to actually send my son Matt who I
think I thought I don't know if he was
my husband at that time I was like just
go look at it I can't even look at it
and then once I passed I would tell
everybody I was so lucky I got the right
professors to ask me the questions that
I knew and that's why I passed the
course and I was just convinced of that
right so now obviously I know that has a
name at the time I didn't know that's
called imposter syndrome even my 10 year
old knows imposter syndrome they teach
it in school now in elementary school so
that's good but at the time I didn't
know I know now also that 70% of the
population has it so the other 30% are
very very loud people and they're
probably
they're at Twitter they're on Twitter
tweeting about themselves so but it does
exist right and I think it was a big
problem for me because in many occasions
I didn't raise my hand when I should
have and I didn't say that I could do it
and I didn't take the opportunity to do
something that was that felt hard so I
don't want that to happen to anybody in
this room anybody can do anything they
want it's just a matter you know of
wanting to do it so even to even
sometimes I get these feelings of
imposter syndrome coming and now I have
two techniques one is whenever I go into
a room and I feel that everybody's
really smart I keep saying I'm playing
up and that's okay and the second thing
I do is I over prepare so even this talk
today you may think it just comes
naturally but actually I did prepare and
I decided to scan a bunch of the papers
that I did as I was preparing for the
talk to give you a sense so if you do
this I think I scribbled around 50 pages
even before I figured out what I was
going to talk about so it's okay to
prepare and admit that you actually work
to get something done okay the next one
is yes it's definitely okay if your
plans change right I think a lot of us
come with plans some people don't have
plans which is also also okay but some
people have plans and then you just
don't know that life is just full of
surprises and things change this is my
dad my dad was a professor in the
University of Barcelona he taught
pediatrics in the medicine department
and he was also a researcher so I was
kind of academics was in the family so I
was destined to be an academic this was
just part of it I actually also spent a
lot of time with him in Spain so I would
go to his lectures and I remember the
first time I went I was probably 7 or 8
and he was as I said teaching pediatric
which is our requirement so in Spain
it's a public university they have this
giant auditoriums and I was in the front
row people are
noisy and as soon as my dad walk did it
was like silence and everybody was
looking up to him I was like wow that's
really important
you know the the other thing you know
what traveling as she was pretty exotic
we had just come out of a dictatorship
people didn't leave Spain but he was
always out you know and scientific
conferences he would go to exotic places
like Russia and Japan India so I thought
this is it
how do you be a professor people are
gonna listen to me I'm gonna go in these
fabulous trips and that was for many
years when I was thought I would do so
when I came to Stanford I did two things
one is I did a lot of teeing so of all
the quarters I was here the only quarter
I did not TA was my first quarter and
every other quarter I was teeing which
is your a Brad student that's trying to
graduate it's almost the kiss of death
because you can't do research right but
I loved it I think my husband was
actually really upset at me because I
would spend so much time with the
students he would come and turn off the
lights on the lab say it was time to go
and I had to go home and over the last
year one of the things I did which was
now in retrospect crazy but I decided I
would rewrite the entire notes of one of
the classes I was teaching and that
class was called E 1:13 and now it's
called EE 101 B and I wrote this little
notes in latech which is also crazy but
III was looking this weekend I saw that
they were still using it which it's a
huge I would made me super happy because
I thought wow transistors have not
changed in 20 years anyway so that's one
thing I did I'm the second thing I did
is I did a lot of research and I was
very fortunate I not only had one PhD
advisor that I had two so I got double
for the price of one I had professor Tom
Lee and professor Stephen Boyd and I my
thesis was he using convex optimization
to design analog circuits it was really
cool I don't have time for that but it
was really cool i well i one of the
things I did in the last six months of
my stay here was I
I have to get a job so you go into this
interviews to be an academic and you
take your research and you go to all
these really fancy schools and you
present your research in front of
professors so this is actually pretty
intense job it's probably worse than the
Qualls
but I did it and at the end I had a
couple of job offers and I was trying to
figure out where to go and all the
sudden I changed my mind I said I'm not
gonna take any of those jobs I'm gonna
go into entrepreneurship so I defended
on March of 1999 I went through this
life crisis where I decided I would not
be a professor I would actually go into
entrepreneurship and I remember talking
to a bunch of people about it but it was
1999 and it was crazy here everybody was
doing startups or a combination of fear
of missing out and you know
encouragement pressure etc made me go
into entrepreneurship so in 60 days I
went actually less than 60 days we went
from defending my thesis to signing a
term sheet without knowing anything and
many times I reflect on that decision do
I regret going into entrepreneurship or
not
fortunately you can't AP test your life
so I you know I'm actually pretty happy
I get to teach so a little bit and lean
launchpad and then through my portfolio
companies and all the students that I
mentor anyways your lives plants can
change and it's ok ok fourth thing is
yes it's really really ok if your first
startup fails so I think also this
happens at Stanford we all have great
great resumes right and I think if
you're really successful failure seems
even you know a bigger risk right but
it's ok to fail I as I mentioned I
started this company called Barcelona
design I still think we had a super cool
logo and we did grade you know we we
actually had a lot going for us our
technology was amazing we were able to
literally design circuits that would
take a human maybe days or weeks to
design we would get pretty close within
a few minutes right so that was pretty
impressive
and that's when computers were slow the
second thing we did which at the time
was definitely crazy was putting the
application on a web browser so it was
really cool we were able to recruit a
lot of great PhDs from here so we had a
stellar team we raised money and we had
customers and that's not even all the
people love me in the press I was a
woman in semiconductors so they had
never seen any of those people so we had
a lot of press right so the company was
high fly out then all the sudden things
started going down so you know I think
there were many reasons there's never
just one thing but it's a combination of
things and you know we we hired a CEO I
don't think that was the problem I think
the issue was I never did get along with
him and I didn't work hard enough to get
along with him so summer one second is
we raised a lot of money and when you
raise too much money you hurt your
company because sometimes because you go
from being kind of nimble and fast to
being comfortable we didn't hire well
the culture was broken so everything was
a mess and I was sitting here and I'm
like okay what slide should I show
what's the picture to show that I was
actually it was terrible luckily I had
my separation agreement so that's it you
can get it all in a piece of paper at
the end where it says Mar we don't need
you anymore
right it's really hard if you're a
founder I think I've in this last 20
years I've met a lot of founders that
have gone through that kind of fail
founders you can start a good a group
called fail founder Anonymous and it
would actually be very successful
because we all feel the same pain and
it's very acute it's like somebody died
you go through the five steps of grief
you you know you're like denial anger
you know depression bargaining and
acceptance right you really suffer that
cycle and at the end once you get to
acceptance it's when it gets good right
because once you get there you can
decide to learn from the experience and
that's what I did once I got there I was
like what could I have done to
make it better and life is just a series
of failure sometimes they warmth and
this doesn't works and their successes
it's just everyday right and I think I
try very very hard every time something
doesn't work do not blame it on anybody
about me because if I do that then I
know that I'm learning from that
experience right so I think for all of
you there will be small big failures it
doesn't matter I think the important
thing is to look at it and say at the
end what could I have done rather than
what could they have done right ok so
obviously I want to start a second
company savio labs but I can tell you
that's kind of like the Apple LTC thing
you don't learn as much when things go
well you learn more when they don't go
well ok so this is the last point the
fifth point and is yes you can learn to
be a great founder great founders are
not necessarily born as you show up and
you're a great founder sometimes I think
this is the most popular question I get
when I give presentations what are you
looking a founder where are you looking
what what makes a good founder etc and
it's hard to give a set of instructions
or set of variables that would translate
into good founders right it's definitely
not take this class have this job you
know learn read this book it's nothing
like that it's really at the core being
a great founder as an exercise on
character you have to overcome your
character flaws and I I really really
believe that you know as humans we we're
not perfect and we have life to go
through to make us better and that's the
way that you can become a great founder
so I have a few suggestions and I'll go
through it it's not a complete list but
if you pick one or two you're doing
great okay the first one is very simple
you have to get started right if you
want to do something you have to start
this sounds very simple and obvious and
maybe not something that would make the
top eight list of more but it has had a
great impact in my life this guy his
name is Ali Hodja Murray
he was my office mate at Stanford he is
probably one of the smartest people I've
ever met he's a electrical engineering
professor at Caltech
he's founded two companies and when we
were students you know
in our 20s and he was this guy that was
60 but it trapped in the body of a 25
year old and he would look at us and
give us advice all the time about what
we should do and shouldn't do and so on
so one day I was on a you know here a
grad student here you've gone through
this period where you're like oh my gosh
what are gonna meet my thesis what am I
gonna work on I don't know I'm never
gonna graduate so I was telling that to
Ali I was like I have these ideas but I
don't know I'll never graduate and Ali
looked at me and said fart the fastest
way to finish is to start which I took
us like stop complaining and get
something done and it's truly what he
meant but I think when we look at
founders you're looking for people that
really think that way if you want to get
something done get started that's the
that's what it takes you don't have to
wait for people you're asked to wait for
money you don't have to wait for
anything just get started the second one
is want it more so I think we look for
founders that just one did more they
want to succeed at all costs right I'll
give you a story about it that for some
of the audience will remember June 19th
2016 I was Game seven of the NBA Finals
and there was the Cavs against the
Warriors the Warriors had had a great
season and the last game was in the
Oakland Stadium so everybody everybody
here in the Bay Area we're all Warriors
fans and we were so happy parties at
people's houses we were gonna win it was
just so clear we were gonna win first
half the Warriors were winning 49 to 42
I'm just very similar to the 49ers we
ended up losing 93 to 89 so it was a big
disappointment I think we became maybe a
little bit too confident the next day we
had John Donoghue come to our office and
John Donoghue is now the CEO of Nike he
was the CEO of eBay service now and Bain
& Company he graduated from Stanford GSB
with an MBA in 1986 and he was there
giving a talk about you know career life
leadership etc and one of the students
hey John you went to school with really
smart people how come you are so
successful and the other people in your
class were not as successful and John
said well because I wanted it more just
like LeBron wanted it more that day and
the final and if you watch that game you
know what I'm talking about because you
could just tell that just LeBron had it
in him to win that game so that's what
we want when we see a founder that power
of wanting to succeed at all cost okay
the third one is do what really matters
first and this is ghost completely
against human nature I think if you have
if you're we're naturally
procrastinators and if you have
something that is hard to do you leave
it until the end you don't want to do it
at the beginning right so it's the
opposite we're actually looking people
that want to do the hard stuff first
I would say that I was a great test
taker I'm sure many people in the
audience are gasps great test takers and
you took the SAT or GRE or whatever and
you know that when you take this test
what you do is you're have to go and
answer as many questions as you can
really really fast and every question is
worth the same so if you find a hard
question you basically don't answer it
and you come back to it that's the
strategy but in a start-up is actually
the opposite you should take the startup
test by doing the following you walk in
and you you read the test and you find
the hardest question and then you answer
just that question and then you pass
because if you don't answer that
question you will not pass right so when
I look at a company now in our portfolio
I'm always trying to figure out what is
the weakest link in this company what do
we have to do to ensure success and I
want the founders to just work on that
because nothing else matters and there's
always ways to keep you busy when you're
in a company always ways to keep you
busy but there's only one thing that
typically matters okay the fourth one is
keep it simple and be super clear so I
named my second company after this guy
this guy is
King and Spain his name is Alfonso
decimal Sevilla which is the tenth the
wise man this King lived in the
thirteenth century and this King is a
special king because he did a lot of
wars to go to a court of wars and so on
but he loved knowledge and education and
he surrounded himself by a bunch of
scholars so he liked history he liked
economics he liked astronomy and he was
very interested in it and at the time
you know the people thought that the
earth was at the center of the universe
right but people were also bored so they
took a lot of measurements of the Stars
and the skies and then they had a
problem because they had all these
measurements and they had the theory and
that said the earth was at the center of
the universe how could they put those
two things together so they they did
they did they had very complicated
systems and one of them what's the poet
LeMay exist them which would have a
planet stand on two spheres it's very
complicated the astronomer was
explaining it to the king and Alfonso
turn around and said if the Lord
Almighty had consulted me before
embarking on creation I should have
recommended something simpler which I
think it's really clever because he
didn't get him into trouble with the
Pope but also because it's true if you
get an explanation and it's really
really complicated it's likely not true
right and if you when it applies to
founders when you're a founder and
you're pitching your company to an
investor you want to keep it simple
we're looking for those people that have
clarity of mine and can communicate
easily what they do it should be simple
right if you're building a product and
the product has ten features or for the
depend on three and you need a very
complicated map to construct it you're
building the wrong product I know if you
are talking to a customer and you're
talking to them about the five great
things your product does it's wrong you
should just give one thing because
that's enough right and customers just
like investors we just are poor people
we don't know enough we just keep it
simple so it's something you have to
exercise on but it's important
okay the fifth one is always be learning
I actually met somebody a few weeks ago
who told me I said oh what do you do and
he said I'm a lifelong learner
I was like wow I want to be that it's
like it's a great job because you're
always learning little by little but
it's true I think you've heard this
before you leave Stanford you have to
keep learning and there's no credit and
there's no classes so how do you do it
I'll tell you a couple of stories this
is a picture of shooby and Ray they're
the founders of a company called
affinity I think this picture is taken
when they were sophomores it's in our
office they look pretty serious but
they're actually really happy people so
I'm not sure what was going on they were
probably trying to look a dolt in this
picture but anyways they they were part
of our group of people and we took them
to Dropbox to talk to Drew the CEO we
went on a little field trip on a bus and
we went there and Ray was the guy
standing up looked at drew and say hey
drew like six years ago you were like
running this company with two people and
now you have a thousand people how did
you become such a great CEO Andrew said
oh that's easy I actually when I run
into something I don't know I go on and
find the best books on the subject and I
read them and I studied them and I try
to really understand them at first I was
caring really expensive consultants but
then I figure out that the best
consultants have books and it's actually
better to read the book because they put
a lot of thought into that book right
I'm in the hour they're talking to me
and that's true I think you've heard it
before but you know Jeff Bezos Mark
Zuckerberg I think this is Patrick
Collinson from stripe he's reading list
it's really interesting actually can go
online and type all these CEOs have
reading lists and this guy has these
books that are like on home construction
and history and they're all over right
it's not about just startups you
actually want your mind to be broad and
open and learn like Alfonso about a
bunch of stuff right so read that's very
easy right okay the second one is ask
for help okay and I'm talking specially
to all those first-time founders that
think everything should be perfect we
know things are not perfect
because we've been there it's really
hard to be a founder and if you don't
ask for help it gets harder right so you
really have to raise your hand when you
don't know something and you know just
get others to help because people
typically help so go back to shooby and
Ray shooby and Ray are actually and you
know they went off to build affinity
affinity is now a hundred people company
in San Francisco they're growing really
fast and two years ago they sent me an
email wrong email and they said hey Mark
basically I tried to summarize it there
we want to make sure we're learning from
the right people can you help us connect
with them right so I think when we get
that email as investors we are like okay
jackpot you know we got founders don't
want to learn and they're aware of what
they don't know so again don't be afraid
to ask for help because I think the best
people in the industry do have help okay
the sixth one is you have to be
confident but with knowledge and I think
confidence is a really touchy thing
because you can be arrogant if you're
too confident and you may be not
paranoid enough if you're confident but
it's important to be confident if you
want to take people with you on your
trip right remember you're a founder and
people have to give you money they have
to buy your product they have to follow
you so I'll tell you a story of one of
the persons that I know I believe has
confidence with the the best level this
is this is door - we invested in door -
in 2013 and my partner peshwa and he was
really gung-ho from day one he was like
oh we should do it we should do it more
and I'm kind of like the analytical
person in that office and I was like I
don't know food who knows I don't know
it's really hard to deliver food I'm not
even sure it's a high-tech business and
did you see all the companies that are
doing food deliveries at the time there
were all these companies I'm probably
more I couldn't find all of them I was
like that's a really bad idea so
basically I took it upon myself to prove
Pechman wrong and I went and they did a
lot of diligence I met
a lot of restaurant owners and I was
like I don't know what do you think of
d'Or - everybody loved it and kind of
the last thing the last test for us was
to go talk to Tony the CEO we I had a
long list of questions ok so very beast
VC like so at your unit economics and
what your growth and your competitors
and blah blah blah blah blah and we went
to their office and their office was
this place in Stanford Avenue this they
had a house student house at the living
room dining room areas where they worked
when they had all these white boards on
the in behind them so you know I went in
with my list and Tony is like no problem
let me get some whiteboards so he got
like three whiteboards and wiped them
all out and he basically answered all my
questions with extreme confidence
fact-based data and me that I'm an
engineer I was completely sold I'm like
okay it does work I should do it so he
basically sold me that I should
definitely give money to this company
right and it's a it he was confident
without you know being arrogant and he
took the time to actually write by hand
everything that I wanted to know so
that's the story and I of course maybe
some of you have used or - okay
the last two are about people so I think
if you're if you're a founder you know
this is not a solo sport you really have
to you can't go public with one person
you actually have to hire people if you
want to build a company and it's really
important to trust the people that you
hire I think Trust is the number one
thing it feels like a soccer team if
you're playing soccer there's a
formation and people basically have
loans that they guard and that's a
responsibility and then everybody else
in the team knows where these people are
so if they pass the ball they know
there's somebody there that should take
it right when you move out of formation
that's when you lose the ball so in
companies is the same you hire the best
people you empower them as much as you
can you want to make people as powerful
as they can be and then you trust them
and if you don't trust them then you
don't move fast
because you're looking back and what are
those guys doing I don't know I don't
trust them and that's not good
right so I think when you're a
first-time founder don't be afraid to
hire somebody that it may be better
forward than you are because that's how
you're gonna win the game and that's
really important and the last one I
would say for me is that I think you
really it's really important to feel
true empathy to whoever you're working
with not just your employees but your
your customers and investors anybody
that surrounds you so I think is really
important to take the time to get to
know what people want to do or where
they want to get what is there what are
their goals so you can align them better
to your company but not just that
because actually you really care so I
think in my case as you know I my first
company didn't work but that was the
best thing that happened to me in order
to be an investor because I know when
somebody's sitting in front of me
pitching me their company it's a really
scary thing right and you don't know
what you're doing and if you're doing it
right and I also know that when I
founder has a problem and there's
problems all the time you can not make
meat sales or you cannot you know your
co-founder is leaving or you have can
raise money I know it's like real pain
right and I cannot at least acknowledge
it and then say okay we got it let's
make a plan let's go fix it right so I
think it's something to work on for all
of us
anyways I leave the list here I could
have gone on I think if I had another
week to prepare for the talk we would
have 16 luckily I don't so couple
minutes Q&A I'm gonna do one more thing
I allowed you today two minutes this is
my research group and I want to tell
ninety-eight I wanted to tell you that
all of us went off most of us went off
and started companies it's not an
accident this is a team that we worked
on in 2014 with garage they were part of
the ACM group at Stanford and I looked
it up everybody started at least one
company so each of you guys here in this
room around you there is a founder I
promise or somebody is my star
than one company so if you have time go
and meet them today don't come talk to
me come talk to the people around you I
got to put a plug for lean launchpad if
you want to meet more founders we have
our final presentations on March 10 and
then just think you have to say - thank
you thank you to Tom again and Tina and
also to the lean launchpad team some of
them are around on my pear team I know
we have a lot of work so thank you and
then my family who's there I want to
thank my husband who uh you know I
wouldn't be here without him I think
he's encouragement at many places in my
career has made it possible for me to be
here today thank you so much yes I think
the question is about hardware companies
right and the fact that they have lower
margins right you know Hardware come and
you know what do people like us there
are investors and there's all these
problems with manufacturing it's always
hard harder I guess to raise money for a
hardware company than a software company
right I would say it's okay because the
world does need hardware and somebody if
you're not you it's gonna actually build
it and make money so if the opportunity
is big enough I think any investor is
willing to take that risk
whether it's margin risk or capital risk
or whatever we only look at it about how
biggest is opportunity it's not whether
you're hardware or software it's just
what's the opportunity that we look at
stick around
don't you join me in thanking your
buddies
[Applause]